mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir ce n'est pas bien sur l'habituel
générique de télé bretagne que vous
venez de voir ceux qui nous suivent et
qui suivent nos émissions depuis le
début auront sans doute reconnu le
premier générique de thé bretagne
actualité celui qui il y a dix ans
maintenant annonçait le premier journal
télévisé régional consacré à la bretagne
oui dix ans déjà que notre ami fernand
leur échec présentait ses actualités
régional de bretagne puisque c'était le
lundi 3 février 1964 un moment essentiel
on peut bien le dire dans l'histoire de
l'information régionale un moment dont
fernand leur échec désormais directeur
régional de la rtf à limoges se souvient
bien entendu